a banda
[Música]
boa noite a todas ea todos é vocês estão
preparados para o luto
você já falaram conversa sobre a morte é
um assunto que nós não falamos nós
evitamos falar sobre ele e hoje vocês
vão ouvir um pouco sobre tudo isso
eu venho de uma adolescência muito
difícil e comunidade como mulher e o
sonho de toda menina adolescente é
conhecer seu príncipe encantado e não é
difícil
a minha história é mais ou menos assim
porque eu achei meu príncipe encantado
diferente dos príncipes encantados das
histórias
ele não tinha um castelo ele não tinha
um cavalo
ele não era branco loiro de olhos azuis
o meu príncipe encantado
ele morava num barraco de favela
ele andava a pé
ele era negro e olhos castanhos
eu me apaixonei pela aquele jovem porque
ele era um atleta que jogava futebol ele
era capoeira ea nossa amizade começou
nos finais de semana eu ia correr e ele
aproveitava ocorrer comigo
pouco tempo depois começamos a namorar e
realizamos o nosso grande sonho casamos
fomos viver na casa da mãe dele pouco
tempo depois nós compramos um
barraquinho lindo maravilhoso e tinha
flores lá dentro
e como todo casal vem o sonho de ter o
seu primeiro filho e ele foi planejado
com humor do mundo e eu tive esse filho
o sonhado que toda mulher quando casa
que hétero e esse sonho foi incrível
os momentos de muita felicidade para mim
nessa época o meu marido ficou
desempregado
na década de 80 e ele tinha uma grande
preocupação todas as vezes que ele saía
de casa ele pegava carteira profissional
e colocava no bolso porque era uma época
em que todos os homens da comunidade ele
tinha que provar que ele era uma pessoa
decente e pra ser decente em uma
comunidade na no capão redondo naquela
época tinha que ter uma carteira
profissional e registrada mas mesmo
desempregado ele colocava aquela
carteira em um dia ele saiu para
trabalhar de pedreiro
ele perdeu o último ônibus e veio de
santo amaro até o jardim ângela a pé
gera muito tarde
logo depois eu fiquei não dormir fiquei
acordado esperando ele chegar
eu ouvi os tiros ea minha vizinha me
chamou
corri até a rua chegando lá o corpo do
meu marido estava estendido no asfalto
já coberto de jornal
nesse momento o policial falou que ele
era suspeito e ele fugiu por isso que
ele foi alvejado
era uma época muito difícil não podia
falar nada a voz do policial era era uma
época que a gente tinha medo do policial
agente não conversava não tinha diálogo
a gente estava lá somente para ouvir o
que ele dizia a gente tinha que aceitar
quando foi no dia seguinte que eu fui
pro ml
meu marido não tinha sido alvejado pelas
costas
ele tinha levado vários tiros no peito
ele foi morto à queima roupa que poderia
eu tinha para fazer
alguma coisa e eu enterrei o meu marido
com filho pequeno para criar e sem ajuda
de ninguém
vencer essa batalha criei meu filho
tempos depois eu casei
hoje eu tenho um casal de filhos e o
tempo passou e meu filho como pai que
ser uma atleta jogador de futebol e
também gostava de capoeira e o meu filho
também gostava de correr comigo ao meu
lado nos finais de semana e isso me
trazia boas lembranças de um passado que
marcou profundamente a minha vida eo meu
filho sonhava em ser jogador de futebol
com as histórias que vocês contar aqui é
muito natural
meninos de comunidade querer ser jogador
de futebol
até de classe média alta e conheço
alguns e aí meu filho foi jogar num
grande time e aí por alguns motivos não
deu certo porque a gente resolveu fazer
a coisa certa e o clube pediu que a
gente fizesse algumas irregularidades e
eu não aceitei e aí meu filho foi
trabalhar normalmente
meu filho de uma empresa de motoboy
tinha moto e sempre saía pelas ruas e
nesse tempo a gente fazia tantos planos
só do sonho de ser jogador de futebol de
ter o patrocínio de uma grande marca de
dar uma vida melhor pra mãe para a
família da gente sair de um barraco de
favela de ter uma moradia digna
todos esses sonhos que mulheres simples
de comunidade dinheiro que nós fazemos
e nesse meio tempo eu fundei a ong
projeto vida corrida trabalhava com
mulheres da comunidade oferecendo
esporte algo que eu fiz minha vida
inteira atletismo que era uma grande
novidade porque em comunidades mulheres
não ocorriam naquela época o meu filho
me pedia para que eu a tendência as
crianças da comunidade porque algumas
crianças estavam se perdendo
fazendo pequenos favores pequenas
entregas aquelas pequenas entregas na
cabeça dele era um passo pra começar a
usar pra cometer pequenos delitos e o
futuro a deus pertence
na época não tínhamos céus tinha
pouquíssimas ongs que fazem atendimento
para jovens e no dia 6 de setembro
meu filho meu filho já casado ver em
casa comemorar o aniversário da minha
mãe da avó dele e aquela noite foi uma
noite incrível
foi uma noite que eu fosse ele está
inspirado ele está apaixonado ainda pra
você se viu passarem o verde
ele chegou e abraçando todo mundo
dizendo que amava eu te amo e a vida
inteira ele nunca foi essa a se
expressar os sentimentos ele sempre
ouvia eu te amo meu filho ele também te
amo e sempre dele eu te amo e aquele dia
ele se apagasse gol com toda a família
demonstrou todo seu amor todo seu
carinho pressentindo que algo iria
acontecer quando terminou a festa ele
saiu poucos segundos ele voltou e aí ele
falou assim mãe
vamos tirar uma foto pra senhora guardar
pra eternidade
porque você só tira foto a gente tinha
uma foto uma maquininha simples e eu
sempre tirava foto deles não tinha essa
coisa de self não tínhamos celular na
época
e aí ele voltou e pediu por uma pessoa
tira uma foto que era pressa fotos e
guardada para a eternidade e marcou
comigo que no sábado viria a almoçar
comigo chegou sábado levantar de
madrugada que é um hábito mil
fui fiz a minha quilometragem fiz uns 15
quilômetros daquele dia
voltei em penha casa fiz tudo e prepare
um belo almoço esperando pelo meu filho
eo meu filho não chegou não chegava
e aí apareceu o primo dele quando eu vi
ele pelo espelho pelo vidro eu falei fab
aconteceu alguma coisa com meu filho ele
falou aconteceu só isso
naquela hora eu não disse mais nada nada
eu fui para um quarto
sentei no chão e passei o resto do dia
aquele tinha meu filho não voltou para
casa
o ciclo natural da vida não aconteceu
que seria meu filho me terra
eu enterrei o meu filho meu mundo
desabou desmoronando e aquele dia foi um
misto de todos os sentimentos e
imagináveis que vocês possam pensar que
passa na cabeça de uma mãe que perde um
filho eu comecei a odiar
eu queria matar eu queria trucidar todo
mundo que tivesse na minha frente porque
meu bem mais precioso
eu tinha que enterrá lo e quando eu
enterrei meu filho eu prometi pra mim
mesma
saindo daquele cemitério que eu tinha
que escrever a minha história não sabia
como
mas eu só sabia que eu tinha essa
vontade
na época existiam jornal que se chamava
notícias populares a gente dizia
e se exprime s ele sairia sangue e por
duas vezes o nome da minha família e
pessoas íntegras pessoas honestas estava
naquele jornal de página policial
e nesse processo de luto
pouco tempo depois saiu foi chamado na
delegacia que descobriram quem é que
tinha assassinado o meu filho pra minha
surpresa quem tinha assassinado o meu
filho foi uma criança
ele só tinha 14 anos um menino de 14
anos em um assalto por ele ter se
apavorado
ele puxou o gatilho ele mal sabia o que
estava fazendo
sabe aquela raiva aquele ódio todo o que
eu estava sentindo naquele momento eu me
coloquei no lugar da mãe daquele menino
toda mãe ama seu filho e eu tenho
certeza que aquela mãe
amava-o fiamma o filho dela como o eu
amo meu e se eu tivesse o poder
a magia de que mais nenhuma mãe no mundo
sente se a dor a falta que eu sentia eu
fazer essa mágica mas eu não tenho esse
poder
e aí eu tomei uma grande decisão na
minha vida sem pensar por que isso ia me
gusta muita dificuldade financeira eu
decidi atender as crianças da comunidade
uma grande
vontade de mudar aquela realidade
até quando os nossos jovens iriam morrer
e eu ainda tinha o filho homem e eu
protegi tanto tanto que um dia ele vai
dar esse relato o que aconteceu de toda
essa super proteção que eu dei pra ele e
pro meu segundo filho
e aí eu comecei a atender as crianças da
comunidade
tive que abdicar metade do meu salário
porque eu ia trabalhar - para poder
atender as crianças da comunidade
foram dez anos investindo tudo que eu
tinha tudo que eu ganhei no projeto que
eu acreditava e que ninguém se
preocupava em ajudar e nem eu sabia que
tinha mecanismo de como fazer isso
dez anos depois eu fui assistir uma
palestra e tava falando de um prêmio eu
escrevi nesse prêmio nunca tinha escrito
nada em dera na época do curso aprendi
vive mexer com mídias sociais se tudo e
para nossa surpresa
nós ganhamos o prêmio primeiro prêmio
game change is mulheres virando o jogo
no esporte eo vida corrida foi eleito o
melhor projeto social de inclusão de
meninas e mulheres porque o público
maior dúvida corrida era de meninas e
mulheres
pouco tempo depois nós já estávamos nas
maiores mídias escritas e faladas e nós
assinamos um contrato jazz já tem dez
anos com a maior marca esportiva do
mundo
nós temos um contrato por tempo
indeterminado
hoje eu vi a corrida é um case de
sucesso pra essa marca eo vida corrida
hoje atende mais de 700 pessoas
diariamente sem nenhuma ajuda do poder
público simplesmente com a ajuda da
iniciativa privada e de amigos que
abraçaram
essa causa e uma coisa que eu falo para
vocês agora não importa quem puxa o
gatilho
retribua fazendo bem porque quando você
puxa o gatilho e você deseja aquela
justiça qualquer preço
nós estamos puxando o gatilho
nós estamos matando mais um jovem que
não teve a oportunidade que muitos aqui
teve de ser tratado com igualdade tudo
que foi dito aqui hoje nesta palestra e
hoje eu vivo só pessoa mais feliz do
mundo uma pessoa que já ouviu essa minha
fala gente se eu morrer amanhã
saiba que morreu a pessoa mais feliz do
mundo porque o cumpri meu papel como
cristã e como se dá essa mesma
comunidade que me tirou meu bem mais
precioso minha família essa comunidade
me deu centenas e centenas de filho hoje
eu sou agraciada todas as manhãs com um
chute de beijos cult que a braços com um
monte de bom dia com mutti de
agradecimentos de falar obrigado por
você fazer parte da minha vida
esse projeto já me deu a oportunidade de
conhecer o mundo
esse projeto realizou meu sonho olímpico
eu conduzir a tocha olímpica na cidade
que me acolheu eu vi olimpíadas coisa
que esta geração nenhuma vai ver mas
nesse país
eu tive o privilégio de ver meu menino
que eu ensinei a brincar de correr por
um pé à frente do o que acelerará dentro
das olimpíadas rio 2016
eu vi meus meninos entrarem na usp
eu vi meus meninos trabalhando nas
multinacionais
tudo através de um projecto que as
pessoas diziam pra mim você tá dando
murro em ponta de faca
você não tem nenhum poder aquisitivo
você não tem formação acadêmica
você acha que você é o que portanto o
marketing
o meu filho ele me fez ser a pessoa que
eu sei hoje eu sou hoje ele veio ao
mundo tá me ensinar a amar aquele menino
que não sabia dizer eu te amo mas ele me
amava intensamente me ama eu sinto a
presença constante dele minha vida e
tudo que eu faço hoje eu faço por ele
combate um bom combate
completem minha corrida e motivo é a fé
e gratidão
muitíssimo obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]